[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und marietta slomka
guten abend auch kabul ist nun gefallen
praktisch der letzte dominostein der der
machtübernahme der taliban in
afghanistan noch im widerstand der
bisherige präsident garnier ist bereits
geflohen die taliban sind seit dem abend
in seinem palast die afghanische armee
scheint in auflösung angehörige der noch
verbliebenen afghanischen regierung
verhandeln mit den taliban offenbar noch
über eine unblutige kapitulation sobald
man in verbindung mit den taliban das
wort unblutig überhaupt verwenden kann
aber zumindest sollen größere kämpfe und
zerstörungen in der hauptstadt vermieden
werden für die bewohner und alle die aus
den provinzen nach kabul flüchteten in
der hoffnung dass die stadt gehalten
wird oder dass sie von dort weiter ins
ausland kommen ist es nun der größte
albtraum katrin eigendorf berichtet
us militärhubschrauber über kabul die
usa bringen ihr botschaftspersonal zum
flughafen amerika und seine verbündeten
verlassen nach 20 jahren das land es
wirkt wie eine flucht auf dem hamid
karzai flughafen chaotische szenen
menschen drängen in die flieger nutzen
die vielleicht noch letzte chance das
land auf dem luftweg zu verlassen die
nachricht vom vorrücken der taliban auf
kabul hat panik ausgelöst vor den banken
drängen die die noch schnell geld
abheben wollen andere decken sich mit
lebensmitteln ein beobachter berichten
bislang gebe es keine kämpfe im
regierungssitz verhandeln die taliban
über eine machtübergabe
präsident ashraf ghani ist ins
benachbarte tadschikistan geflüchtet
der ehemalige präsident hat afghanistan
verlassen und die menschen dieser
situation überlassen gott wird ihn zur
rechenschaft ziehen und das volk wird
sein urteil über ihn haben
das alles so friedlich bleibt daran gibt
es viele zweifel aufnahmen die zeigen
wie die taliban in kabul ein gefängnis
stürmen und ihre kämpfer befreien aus
dem provinz metropolen die bereits
erobert sind berichten menschen von
gräueltaten vor allem an jungen frauen
aus herat erreicht uns die nachricht
dass taliban kämpfer verlangt haben alle
unverheirateten mädchen ab 15 jahren an
sie herauszugeben was wir nicht zeigen
können sportlerinnen journalistinnen die
sich zu hause verstecken aus angst auch
uns erreichen heute immer wieder
hilferufe von menschen die um ihr leben
fürchten die armee das haben die letzten
tage gezeigt ist ohne westliche
unterstützung nicht in der lage das land
zu verteidigen überall geben die
soldaten kampflos auf doch nicht alle
fliehen hamid karzai afghanistans erster
frei gewählter präsident den wir noch im
juni interviewt hatten und der sich aus
der politik zurückziehen wollte er
greift jetzt verantwortung
wir versuchen mit den taliban führern in
friedlicher brüderlicher und
patriotischer weise zu sprechen um
afghanistans probleme zu lösen
doch klar ist heute über den
regierungsgebäuden von kabul könnte
schon bald die flagge der taliban wen
das ist der worst case für alle afghanen
die sich vor den taliban fürchten und
die armen in welche zeiten irland nun
zurück geschleudert wird es ist aber
auch worst case für den westen ein
desaster das man am ende sehenden auges
hineingegangen ist und dass noch viele
folgen haben kann für die region für
afghanistans nachbarländer für europa in
den nächsten tagen wird es aber erst mal
um eine frage gehen wie viele leute kann
die bundesregierung dort jetzt noch
rausholen warum beginnt die evakuierung
in kabul erst jetzt wo die taliban schon
vor der tür stehen und was ist mit den
afghanischen ortskräfte die der
bundeswehr kundus und masar i scharif
geholfen haben haben diese menschen
jetzt überhaupt noch eine chance in
berlin wird bereits scharf über
versäumnisse debattiert nicole diekmann
berichtet es ist ein kurzes statement
dass der außenminister am abend abgibt
nach einem langen tag voller
krisensitzungen es ist ein
niederschmetterndes fazit das er zieht
nach 20 langen jahren bundeswehreinsatz
in afghanistan
hier und auf der ganzen welt müssen mit
ansehen wie schnell die taliban die
kontrolle übernommen haben und wie wenig
die afghanischen streitkräfte
dem entgegenzusetzen haben teile der
afghanischen regierung befinden sich
bereits im ausland haben das land
verlassen und die machtübergabe
machtübernahme der taliban steht
unmittelbar bevor
unmittelbar bevor steht auch der start
dieser transportflugzeuge aus dem
niedersächsischen wunstorf noch heute
nacht an bord und es wäre soldaten ihr
ziel lautet kabul und ihr ziel lautet
menschen dort rausholen so viele wie
möglich es ist ein gefährlicher einsatz
indem wir sie jetzt schicken und ich
darf alle in deutschland bitten dass sie
in gedanken bei unseren soldatinnen und
soldaten und den menschen vor ort sind
die wir jetzt nach deutschland bringen
aber auch dänen die in einer sicherlich
schwierigen zeit jetzt in afghanistan
bleiben die politik im ausnahmezustand
die folge äußerst ungewöhnliche
gemeinsame schnittmengen im
zdf-sommerinterview fordert fdp chef
lindner die schnelle unbürokratische
aufnahme der menschen aus afghanistan
warnt aber auch vor einer neuen
flüchtlings die partie
die bundesregierung muss auf der
internationalen bühne jetzt dafür sorgen
dass eine situation die 2015 in syrien
sich nicht wiederholt also mit dem
flüchtlingshilfswerk und anderen
partnern muss im umfeld von afghanistan
jetzt eine infrastruktur aufgebaut
werden um flüchtende menschen dort zu
schützen ihnen dort menschenwürdige
umstände zu bieten sehr ähnliche töne
von der spd sonst selten einig mit den
liberalen fürchtet man auch hier das
thema flüchtlinge mitten im
bundestagswahlkampf ich glaube das kann
man wahrscheinlich zurzeit heute schon
bewährten dass insbesondere pakistan
iran die diejenigen länder sein werden
die sehr stark auch von flüchtlingen aus
afghanistan
betroffen sein werden und wir müssen
auch diese länder dabei unterstützen
eine weitere ungewöhnliche allianz
bundesinnenminister seehofer csu
bezeichnet den afghanistan-einsatz in
einem interview als ein desaster und
erntet volle zustimmung von der linken
ein solches desaster nach über 20 jahren
ist wirklich kaum zu verantworten so
viel tote zivile opfer 59 tote
bundeswehrsoldaten 13 milliarden euro
versenkt und dann dieses chaos und
währenddessen haaren menschen in
afghanistan aus in sogenannten safe
hauses wie hier in kabul in verstecken
in denen sie nur hoffen können gerettet
zu werden
experte markus kaim von der stiftung
wissenschaft und politik die auch die
bundesregierung berät ist uns
zugeschaltet guten tag ein guter song
hätten wir uns erstmal über das
naheliegende reden warum kommen diese
evakuierung also wie schätzen sie das
ein warum kommen die so später hätte man
doch eigentlich vertragen spätestens mit
anfangen müssen oder mich wirklich ich
will nicht ungerecht sein weil die
amerikanischen geheimdienste am dienstag
glaube ich war es noch verkündet sie
gingen davon aus dass 30 bis 90 tage
noch reichen würden um kabel zu halten
dann will die stadt erst fallen und die
gut informierten amerikanischen
geheimdienste waren also sie
offensichtlich eine illusion aufgesessen
dementsprechend tue ich mich erklärt die
bundesregierung dafür zu kritisieren
dass sie keine weiteren vorkehrungen
getroffen hat ich glaube die entwicklung
beeinflussen und nicht so vorhersehbar
ist eigentlich dann noch schlimmer das
hat mich mal so viel aufklärung in dem
land gibt nach dem abzug dass man solche
entwicklungen vorhersehen kann also
militärische aufklärung meine ich jetzt
in der tat was wir jetzt sehen ist der
totale zerfall einer der afghanischen
sicherheitskräfte wir haben uns auf das
spiel konzentriert die westlichen
regierung indem sie immer auch die zahl
der existierenden soldaten verwiesen
haben in ausbildung land den
ausrüstungsstand und dabei aus dem blick
außer blick verloren dass es um etwas
ganz anderes geht nämlich um politische
loyalität und was sie jetzt feststellen
ist das weite teile der afghanischen
sicherheitskräfte überhaupt nicht loyal
gegenüber der zentralregierung in
afghanistan gewesen sind und die ein
atemberaubender geschwindigkeit ihrer
uniform die waffen die ausrüstung von
sich geworfen haben hinzu kommt
natürlich weiß auch dass mit den
amerikanern zum beispiel auch den
vertragsfirmen abgezogen sind die sich
um die wartung von hubschraubern und
ähnlichem gekümmert haben also so toll
ausgestattet waren die afghanen dann
wohl am ende auch gar nicht mehr als sie
allein waren
das mag auch die fans an der kleine
punkt ist dass der westen viele
westliche hauptstädte sie über 20 jahre
an der illusion hingegeben habe die
stadt ja aber sich als kräftig gewesen
sind und das war der hauptaufgabe des
nato auftrags in afghanistan eben
sicherheitskräfte aufzubauen wie
selbständig und wirksam auf dem gesamten
staatsgebiet afghanistans für sicherheit
sorgen konnten und das ist das größte
defizit dieses einsatzes gewesen wie wir
jetzt feststellen jetzt ist jedenfalls
der militärische druck was als haupt
fand wenn man so will gegenüber den
taliban ja quasi aus der hand gegeben
hat man jetzt überhaupt noch
möglichkeiten seine
verhandlungssituation zu haben zum
beispiel was jetzt auch die sicherheit
von von ortskräfte namen angeht da sehe
ich wenig also sie deutlich jahren durch
die entscheidung vom april als der
amerikanische präsident
angekündigt hat die us truppen
abzuziehen hat er angekündigt dass die
absolut bedingungslos sein würde keine
politischen rahmenbedingungen müssten
mehr erfüllte und keine mit ihrer klaren
bedingungen sollten wir erfüllt werden
und dadurch ist diese fatale kette von
ereignissen in gang gesetzt worden die
wir jetzt sehen oder deren dessen
höhepunkt in anführungsstrichen wrc
dementsprechend sehe ich jetzt nie
wieder west noch einfluss nehmen könnte
was bleibt ist eine vergleichsweise
trotzige reaktion auf der
bundesregierung wir werden keine
verhandlungen führen gewähren die
taliban nicht anerkennen die wenig geld
geben das kann ich in diesen tagen
verstehen diese reaktion aber das ist ja
keine grundlage für eine politik für
eine region für anlagen für den nächsten
jahre denn entwicklungsgelder fehlen
könnte das am ende auch den den
flüchtlings druck von deutsche politik
angst hat er noch weiter erhöhen
absoluter höhepunkt ist völlig richtig
70 bis 80 prozent der afghanischen
bevölkerung geklärt sind auf
internationale hilfszahlungen angewiesen
und diese zu entziehen würde die
humanitäre situation hier ohnehin jetzt
regiert zu werden droht noch weiter
verschärfen und es würde genau das
auslösen was sie angesprochen haben
nämlich dass der migrationsdruck
außerhalb des landes und in richtung
europa noch erhöht wird wenn ich die
solche politik aus dem letzten teil
richtig verstanden habe sondern genau
das verhindert werden manchmal an den
anfang des afghanistan einsatzes
verändert da ging es ja vor allem darum
dass die taliban sich als überaus
freundliche gastgeber für al qaida
stichwort september der welt
präsentierten könnte das wieder so
werden dass afghanistan so eine art
terroristischen lisa wird also auch hier
wieder die amerikanischen geheimdienste
gehen davon aus dass es zwei jahre
dauern würde nach der macht egal von der
taliban das gruppen wie al-qaida oder
ist da müssen staat in der lage wären
anschläge wieder in westlichen
hauptstädten zu verfügen von daher ist
auch schon ein gewisser
unsicherheitsfaktor
es deutet sich etwas anders die usa und
auch andere länder weiter
terrorbekämpfung in afghanistan machen
werden nur nicht mit massiver
militärischer präsenz vor ort sondern
mit luftschlägen mit spezialkräften mit
drohnenangriffen ausblasen zum beispiel
in zentralasien
da sind die us ja gerade im gespräch mit
des pakistan wird bei auch von basen aus
aus pakistan und von flugzeugträgern im
persischen golf also terrorbekämpfung in
afghanistan wird weiter auf der agenda
der internationalen gemeinschaft stehen
und das flüchtlingsproblem wird man da
nicht auch mit der türkei wieder reden
müssen vielleicht auch mit den mullahs
in teheran
in der tat in die erfahrung zeigt dass
der großteil von flüchtlingen krisen
erstmal im land bleiben das wird in
afghanistan immer schwerer werden und es
deutet sich an dass zwei länder jetzt
besondere flüchtlingsströme aufnehmen
werden nämlich iran und pakistan
und ich glaube werden wir es ernst
meinen mit dem anliegen die zufrieden
dass die afghanischen flüchtlingen die
türkei betreten dann muss man
sicherstellen dass im iran bleiben und
in pakistan bleiben und dann haben
diejenigen einen punkt die sagen wir
brauchen eine große
unterstützungsleistung vielleicht eine
politische initiativen europäischen
union im verbund mit den vereinten
nationen die entsprechenden instrumente
und hilfswerke unterhält für flüchtlinge
rund um den globus er kann franken für
diese einschätzung einer sehr gerne
zur kapitulation kabul thun 1 kommentar
vom chefredakteur des zdf peter frey
das scheitern kommt schneller als das
politiker und diplomaten für möglich
gehalten haben jetzt fällt auch kabul in
die hände der taliban der steinzeit
islam wird in afghanistan wieder
bestimmen die afghanen fliehen zu
hunderttausenden der westen das muss man
heute so hart sagen hat alle verraten
die an demokratie und gleichheit der
geschlechter an bildung für mädchen an
musik tanz und lachen geglaubt haben
milliarden-investitionen in sicherheit
und infrastruktur
viele soldaten die am hindukusch
gefallen sind alles umsonst in wenigen
wochen ja tagen geopfert es ist eine
schmerzhafte niederlage des westens
bilder wie bei der überstürzten flucht
der us-truppen aus saigon am ende des
vietnamkriegs sowie barack obama in
syrien verweigert auch der neue
demokratische us präsident joe biden
welt politische verantwortung weil er
sie seinem volk nicht zumuten will es
ist ein würdeloses ende und eine
einladung an russland china indien und
pakistan
das vakuum zu füllen
der fall von kabul zeigt schonungslos
dass deutschland und die anderen nato
staaten ohne die usa militärisch nicht
handlungsfähig sind ohne deren
absicherung kann selbst das
botschaftspersonal nicht ausgeflogen
werden einst unentbehrlich ortskräfte
und ihrer familien müssen jetzt um ihr
leben bangen zum politisch militärischen
versagen kommt ein schmerzhaftes
moralisches wenn man die im stich lässt
die das lokale rückgrat von zwei
jahrzehnten afghanistan einsatz waren
gerd schröder und angela merkel sowie
ihre außen- und verteidigungsminister
hatten sich die überzeugung von peter
struck zu eigen gemacht dass
deutschlands sicherheit am hindukusch
verteidigt wird wenn der satz je stimmte
dann steht es um unsere sicherheit seit
heute schlechter
wieder frei kommentierte und dann
blicken wir noch auf einen anderen ort
des schreckens nach dem schweren
erdbeben in haiti sprechen die behörden
dort inzwischen von mehr als 700 toten
auch dass nur eine vorläufige zahlen die
rettungsarbeiten sind schwierig und
gefährlich es gibt nachbeben und zu
allem überfluss rückt jetzt auch noch
ein tropischer sturm an das zentrum des
bebens lag etwa 150 kilometer westlich
der hauptstadt portugals
es soll sogar bis nach kuba zu spüren
gewesen sein und trifft mit haiti ein
krisenland dass ich bis heute noch nicht
von dem verheerenden beben von 2010
erholt hat claudia bertz berichtet
die hilfe kommt so sieht es aus aber wie
so oft in haiti sie ist auch eine frage
von arm oder reich ein politiker hat ein
privates ambulanzflugzeug gemietet um
verletzte aus dem entlegenen
erdbebengebiet in die hauptstadt zu
bringen
es gab noch nachgeben es sind so viele
verletzt wir brauchen wirklich hilfe
viele sind tot wir brauchen so viele
medikamente hilfe von den behörden von
der internationalen gemeinschaft
doch noch sind die abgelegenen
krankenhäuser weitgehend auf sich
gestellt hilfe ist unterwegs aber oft
noch nicht da so werden die verletzten
notdürftig draußen versorgt aber es sind
einfach viel zu viele
können die gesamtsituation noch gar
nicht bewerten die lage ist sehr
kritisch und wir müssen unsere
ressourcen aufteilen und auch in andere
stark betroffene gebiete schicken die
situation am tag danach haben sie hier
immerhin ein bagger der die größten
trümmer beseitigt so steigen sie unter
den schutt in der hoffnung hier noch
überlebende zu finden
tausende sind ohne dach über dem kopf
sie hausen in provisorischen zelten auf
dem fußballplatz die internationale
hilfe wie aus den usa ist angelaufen mal
wieder und wieder wird sie dem land
nicht langfristig helfen die
verzweiflung hier ist auf der
internationalen prioritätenliste nicht
weit oben und das sind so viele krisen
hier
etwas mehr als einem monat ermordet das
hat natürlich schön groß politisches
vakuum gesorgt was in einem land in dem
sowieso schon relative politische
instabilität und die fragilität herrscht
seit mehreren jahren sozusagen noch
obendrauf kamen und das jetzt gepaart
mit dem erdbeben ist setzt die die die
humanitäre lage
aber trotz der zerstörung gibt es auch
hoffnung denn die betroffene region ist
insgesamt nicht so dicht besiedelt daher
hoffen und beten die menschen dass es
nicht so verheerend wird wie nach dem
großen erdbeben von 2010
zurück nach deutschland das letzte zdf
politbarometer hat ja unterschiedliche
reaktionen ausgelöst freud und leid
lagen nahe beieinander
olaf scholz und seine spd bitte an
jedenfalls morgenluft sogar eine kanzler
perspektive nur genügend dafür ja nicht
nur sehr gute persönliche umfragewerte
für den spd-spitzenkandidaten
um regieren zu können braucht es
bekanntlich eine parlamentarische
mehrheit und die würde es nach jetzigen
stand nur mit einer dreier koalition
geben da kommt natürlich die fdp ins
spiel beim letzten mal wollte sie ja
nicht mitregieren inzwischen will sie
das sogar sehr aber mit wem wäre eine
ampel mit spd und grünen für sie
überhaupt keine option
das wurde christian lindner im zdf
sommerinterview heute natürlich auch
gefragt thomas reichert hat die
wichtigsten interviews für uns
zusammengefasst
christian lindner sieht sich fast schon
in der regierung nicht in eine
ampel-koalition dafür fehle die fantasie
sondern mit der union die so lindner im
zdf sommerinterview
trotz abstürzender umfragen am ende doch
vorne liegen werde deshalb erwarte ich
eine regierungsbildung unter führung der
union wegen der des momentums und ich
glaube dass das eine sache der union
wäre dass weitere format zu bestimmen
also diese so genannte jamaika oder
deutschland koalition heißt lindner
rechnet unter anderem mit jenem bündnis
mit union und grünen das jahr 2017 bei
den sondierungen noch platzen ließ es
ist besser nicht zu regieren als falsch
zu regieren der satz wäre ihm damals
politisch fast zum verhängnis geworden
nun soll er helfen beim machtpoker und
die profilierung besonders gegenüber den
grünen wir haben 2017 jahr den damals
von frau merkel mit den grünen geplanten
links shift unseres landes ich denke nur
an die frage der einwanderungspolitik
damals das haben wir verhindert und so
kann ich auch in diesem jahr sagen eine
weitere verschiebung nach links einen
solchen weg könnten wir nicht mitgehen
lindner hofft auf klimaschutz durch
innovation ist dabei gegen die förderung
von e-autos gegen ein ende des
verbrechers weil in den
verbrennungsmotor können wir auch
synthetisches benzin das mit
erneuerbarer energie in chile produziert
wird einfüllen und das müssen wir auch
den werben ja millionen autos auf den
deutschen straßen klima experten sehen
das anders synthetisches benzin sei viel
zu teuer außerdem zu knapp lindner das
klimakonzept reiche nicht aus allein auf
den markt und auf innovationen zu setzen
ist nicht ausreichend da habe ich den
eindruck da wird die fdp in der zeit die
wir haben auch bis 2050 allein mit dem
markt nicht weiterkommen lindner
verteidigte im zdf das steuerkonzept der
fdp dass bestverdiener mit
jahreseinkommen über 300.000 euro
besonders stark entlastet werden hohes
einkommen hat zahlt allerdings auch mehr
steuern menschen die so ein einkommen
beziehen beziehen das ja oftmals in
unserem land nicht für sich sondern es
das einkommen ihres werks betriebs aus
dem auch dann die wirtschaftliche
substanz erbracht werden muss
zusammengerechnet bedeuten die
fdp-vorschläge ein defizit von bis zu 90
milliarden euro für die öffentlichen
kassen wie das konkret finanziert werden
soll sagte lindner nicht
und jetzt macht erstmal gundela weiter
mit anderen nachricht mit target die
westafrikanische elfenbeinküste hat den
ersten ebola fall seit mehr als 25
jahren gemeldet einer aus dem
nachbarland guinea eingereiste junge
frau ist an der viruserkrankung
gestorben der jüngsten epidemie in der
region zwischen 2014 und 16 waren 11.000
menschen zum opfer gefallen damals war
die weltgesundheitsorganisation für ihr
zu langsames handeln kritisiert worden
jetzt lässt die whu schnellstmöglich
5000 impfdosen in die elfenbeinküste
bringen
rund ein jahr nach der
explosionskatastrophe in beirut wird der
libanon erneut von einer schweren
detonation erschüttert mindestens 20
menschen sind dabei ums leben gekommen
dutzende wurden verletzt ein
treibstofflager hatte sich im norden des
landes aus noch ungeklärter ursache
entzündet die armee erklärte sie habe
dort illegal gelagertes benzin
beschlagnahmt das an einwohner verteilt
werden sollte der libanon befindet sich
in einer schweren wirtschaftskrise
benzin und andere güter sind knapp
extreme wetterbedingungen machen
weiterhin millionen menschen in weiten
teilen europas zu schaffen bei den
überschwemmungen im norden der türkei
ist die zahl der todesopfer auf 58
gestiegen zugleich bleibt wegen der
trockenen hitze in vielen regionen
südeuropas die brandgefahr hoch in
griechenland wurden über 50 neue brände
gezählt die aber unter kontrolle sind
und auch israel leidet unter anhaltend
hohen temperaturen nahe jerusalem ist
ein waldbrand ausgebrochen der sich
schnell ausbreitete etwa 10.000 anwohner
mussten ihre häuser verlassen
im verlauf der pandemie hat sich in
deutschland die zahl der selbständigen
die auf grundsicherung angewiesen sind
versechsfacht der chef der bundesagentur
für arbeit scheele sagte der funke
mediengruppe bis juli hätten rund
134.000 selbstständige hartz iv
beantragt üblicherweise seien es im
vergleichbaren zeitraum etwa
22.000 das robert koch institut
registrierte
4728 neuinfektionen
1601 mehr als vor einer woche drei
weitere todesfälle gab es im
zusammenhang mit 19 die sieben tage
incidents ist weiter gestiegen auf glatt
sein erster trainer beim fc bayern ein
jugoslawe nannte ihn kleines dickes
müller das war liebevoll gemeint
überhaupt war gerd müller ein spieler
der sehr geliebt wurde von den fans die
von den mitspielern dass herr figürlich
er die kompaktklasse vertrag hat ihm
auch keineswegs geschadet niemand konnte
so aus dem nichts heraus das runde ins
eckige bringen immer und immer wieder
müller tore machten die gegner
regelrecht fassungslos zack war der ball
schon wieder drin wie kann jemand so
wendig sein so reaktionsschnell er war
der könig des strafraums jetzt ist er im
fußballer himmel und zwar dort wo nur
die größten hinkommen ein nachruf von
boris büchler
er war ein gesicht der bundesliga einer
der größten stürmer den das land je
hatte mit der nationalmannschaft wird
der 1972 europameister
er entwickelt sich zu einem der besten
stürmer der welt
unvergessen sein siegtor im wm finale
1974 gegen die niederlande
[Applaus]
der bomber der nation wie er genannt
wird gewinnt alles was man als fußballer
gewinnen kann
als 18 jähriger wechselte er zum fc
bayern und prägt mit sepp maier und
franz beckenbauer eine ära tore sind
sein markenzeichen oder zum könig des
strafraums zwischen 1974 und 76 gewitter
mit den bayern dreimal nacheinander den
europapokal der landesmeister
eine stürmer-legende mit
365 treffern bis heute der mit abstand
erfolgreichste torschütze der bundesliga
es müllert ob aus der drehung im fallen
oder im sitzen
nach seiner karriere arbeitete er im
jugendfußball und als co trainer der
bayern amateure
doch dann erkrankte er schwer müller
litt seit jahren an alzheimer und lebte
seit 2015 in einem pflegeheim heute am
frühen morgen ist er im alter von 75
jahren gestorben
die fußball welt trauert um gerd müller
noch eine ausführliche erinnerung an
gerd müller sind es das zdf nachher um
0.50 und mit fußball macht gundelach
jetzt auch noch mal weiter
zu den sonntagsspielen der bundesliga in
beiden stadien wurde zunächst der
verstorbenen fußball legende gedacht in
köln gewann dann der gastgeber erst der
fc köln gegen hertha bsc 3 zu 1 auch in
dem anderen sonntagsspiel gegen
überraschend der korona bedingt in der
spielerauswahl etwas limitierte
gastgeber mit einem sieg vom platz mainz
05 besiegte vizemeister rb leipzig 1 zu
0 in abwesenheit von titelverteidiger
jan frodeno hat triathlet patrick wilson
die ironman europameisterschaft in
frankfurt am main gewonnen für die drei
disziplinen schwimmen radfahren und
laufen benötigte der schwede sieben
stunden 59 minuten und 21 sekunden und
war damit knapp eine minute schneller
als der däne mögen auch bester deutscher
wurde franz löschke auf platz fünf
speerwerfer johannes vetter hat sich
nach seiner enttäuschenden leistung bei
den olympischen sommerspielen mit einem
soliden sieg beim speerwurf meeting in
seiner heimatstadt offenburg
zurückgemeldet zwar blieb der ex
weltmeister mit seinem wurf auf gut 86
meter unter seinen möglichkeiten aber
die motivation bleibt für sich und
andere speerwerfer gleiche bedingungen
zu fordern in tokio hatte fette probleme
mit einem neuartigen hightech belag auf
der anlaufbahn
und damit kommen wir zu unserem
sonntäglichen ausblick auf die nächste
woche interessant wird zum beispiel sein
was die stiko zum thema kinderimpfungen
sagen wird ein mitglied der kommission
hat angekündigt dass es im laufe der
woche eine aktualisierung der stiko
empfehlung geben wird weitere themen und
termine hat jetzt dara hassanzadeh
[Musik]
am mittwoch wird in brüssel ein
sondertreffen der eu-innenminister
stattfinden thema der massive anstieg
illegaler grenzübertritte von belarus
nach litauen nach erkenntnissen der eu
ist belarus dafür verantwortlich
präsident lukaschenko hat in der
vergangenheit offen gedroht flüchtlinge
passieren zu lassen
am donnerstag wird sich der august
putsch in moskau jahren vor 30 jahren
fuhren panzer in der moskauer innenstadt
auf präsident gorbatschow wurde für
amtsunfähig erklärt und isoliert eine
gruppe sowjets funktionäre wollte das
alte system wieder errichten
scheiterte am widerstand von boris
jelzin und tausende moskowiter unter
ihnen auch ein junger politiker namens
vladimir putin
am freitag wird bundeskanzlerin angela
merkel eben diesen putin in moskau
treffen dabei wird es vor allem um
sicherheitsfragen gehen insbesondere um
den ukraine konflikt den sie zu
schlichten versucht deshalb wird sie von
moskau weiter nach kiew reisen in beiden
ländern wird es wohl merkels letzter
staatsbesuch sein
am samstag wird es im new yorker central
park ein großkonzert geben damit werden
die new yorker das ende der chor ohne
einschränkungen in ihrer stadt feiern
verschwunden ist das corona virus
allerdings noch nicht seit august
steigen wieder die zahlen auf über 5.000
neuinfektionen pro tag
und das wetter wird in der neuen woche
unbeständiger es kommt ein tief und der
deutsche wetterdienst warnt vor heftigen
gewittern schon in der nacht vor allem
in den südlichen mittelgebirgen
morgen gibt es vor allem in der
nordhälfte sowie an den alpen zeitweise
kräftigen regen und gewitter vom
schwarzwald bis zur oder aber auch
größere sonnige abschnitte das ganze bei
teils stürmischem westwind und 17 bis 26
grad am dienstag wechselhaft und sehr
windig bei 16 bis 21 grad danach wird es
wieder etwas freundlicher
das war es von uns weitergeht vielleicht
mit der ersten folge der serie mirage
gefährliche lügen kurz gesagt entdeckt
eine frau dass ihr seit 15 jahren tot
geglaubter man offenbar sehr lebendig
ist klassischer stoff also für einen
zähler
und die nächste heute express gibt es
hier im programm um 0 45 minuten amt auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]